Marcus you've a similar thing would love
actually wear suddenly people were going
oh not with that face I never knew that
was what was beneath those t-shirts
today no I guess the point we'd love
actually it was me it was not meant to
be sexy it was meant to be kind of
innocent and so it wasn't that um you
know when you do sex scenes that aware
you are giving that you know when you're
when you're acting that that's a little
bit more vulnerable making it I mean
it's a bit more about Biggers
you know inevitably you're kind of
giving away some of your own state
secrets there you know II love actually
the way it was dialogue you know it was
like the funny bit about it was that it
was two very ordinary people it wasn't
meant to be turning anyone on you know
okay so if it did you with it Oh
I wasn't expecting to see that I'm
making the other pot yeah I'm not fully
naked you get a little purse you get a
little person a change purse yeah and
it's some marking surface we call it and
the woman gets a strip made it something
but sometimes are you working for
so you know and I've been told at drama
school if you don't lay off the church
and let it play Juliet you don't plan on
shooting this at night do you like yeah
it's a night he's like well they hunt at
night it really gives it more dangerous
at night he's like it's around 30 to 40